In one cross-test, the Foundation thought
SCP-682, the Hard to Destroy Reptile, would
bite off more than it could chew with SCP-807,
a deadly plate from the Last Chance Diner.
This plate makes any food placed on it
extra delicious, but also makes them extra
unhealthy - so unhealthy that people who eat
its food tend to die of massive heart attacks.
They used the plate to transmute two
SCP-682 Specials - a mix of 10 kg of
rotten meat and sharpened bone splinters, 10
L of rancid mayonnaise, 1 L potassium cyanide,
and 1 kg morphine hydrochloride -
considered a 5-star course for our pal
SCP-682 - and fed it to the beast.
At first, it seemed immobile. Perhaps the
monster had been bested? But when D-Classes
entered to check, the creature’s
skin ruptured in several areas,
ejecting high-pressure jets of
its own blood in every direction,
killing them all. The reptile was completely fine
afterward and eagerly ate a third 682 Special.
In one cross-test, the Hard to Destroy
Reptile SCP-682 was made to face off against
SCP-689, the terrifying Haunter in the Dark,
a statue that can induce death in anyone who
looks at it and then stops paying attention.
The statue was placed in 682’s chamber, and
the lights were turned off for five minutes.
When the lights were turned back on, 682
laid motionless in a pile of dark, grey goo.
When a D-Class was sent in to confirm the kill,
682 suddenly rose back up to its feet and devoured
him in an instant. Two swift chomps with its
razor sharp teeth, and the D-Class was history.
It seems that 682 doesn’t fit the same
definition of “alive” as us humans,
and, as a result, was unaffected by the Haunter
in the Dark. Frighteningly, 682 was also smart
enough to intuit 689’s anomalous ability and used
this knowledge to play dead and attempt escape.
It’s the clash of the titans: SCP-682,
the Hard to Destroy Reptile, vs SCP-096,
the terrifying, murderous Shy
Guy. But who won this battle?
Well...It was kind of a draw. Their
battle lasted for 27 whole hours,
and ended in a brutal stalemate, with
SCP-096 severely injured and huddled
in one corner of the room, and 682 in the
other, missing 85% of its original body mass.
The creatures were both brought back
to their chambers with relative ease.
A fight like this can never happen again, because
now, whenever 096 is brought too close to 682,
it turns away, shrieks, and
begins clawing at its own face.
In one cross test, SCP-682, the Hard to Destroy
Reptile, was made to face off against SCP-1361,
a giant, aggressive mass of animal slurry
that envelops and digests everything it touches,
before briefly taking on their traits.
Just over 1000 kilograms of SCP-1361 was poured
onto SCP-682, and it successfully enveloped
the creature.
The problem was that it then began taking
on traits and a temperament incredibly similar
to SCP-682 - After developing legs, jaws and
other physical features similar to the reptile,
it broke out of containment and killed seventeen
members of staff.
After several failed attempts to stop the
creature with small arms fire, it was finally
destroyed by the aerial deployment of napalm.
682’s skeletal carcass was retrieved from
within and placed back in its chamber.
It had regenerated back to perfect health
within a mere six hours.
We all have that one friend, we just can’t
take anywhere with us without a little explanation
and a whole lot of embarrassment.
Nobody expected what would happen when the
SCP Foundation cross-tested SCP-682, the Hard
to Destroy Reptile, with SCP-082, a giant,
aggressive humanoid called Fernand the Cannibal.
When they presented Fernand with a tissue
sample of 682, he said, “Oh, splendid!
My friend lives!”
When he entered the containment chamber, 682
immediately attempted to flee from him, despite
Fernand claiming they were friends who went
way back - And, in fact, 682 had once been
his loyal steed.
After extended fighting, Fernand began to
ride 682, an experience the reptile found
supremely humiliating.
Once 082 left, the giant was delighted, and
SCP-682 said something about him that we can’t
repeat if we want to keep monetization on
this video.
In one particularly exciting cross test, the
Foundation set SCP-682, the infamous Hard
to Destroy Reptile, against SCP-204, a cloud
of deadly, all-consuming nanites bonded to
a small child for the purposes of protecting
them.
As SCP-682 naturally attacked the child, the
nanites sprung into action, forming the shape
of a huge warrior with an axe and shield.
The battle was intense, but amazingly, despite
taking tremendous damage itself, the SCP-204
warrior kicked the stuffing out of SCP-682.
As is expected of SCP-204, its nanites began
feeding on SCP-682’s immobilized body.
But, surprise surprise,
SCP-682 started regenerating
faster than the nanites could eat it.
It then began to attack SCP-204 once again.
The Foundation tranquilized both parties,
and hosed SCP-682 with hydrochloric acid,
before returning them both to their chambers.
All anomalies contained.
No children harmed.
Delegating a high-priority task to a person
who only delivers a bare-minimum style of
work ethic otherwise, will probably result
in the task not getting done.
The Foundation tried to snuff out SCP-682
with the help of SCP-2599, formerly known
as Zena Cho, a woman of Korean descent who’ll
carry out any order you give her...But only
around halfway.
That’s why the Foundation ordered her to
attack 682 until it was “200% dead”, so
even if she only did her task by halves, it’d
still be 100% dead.
By all accounts, she was actually doing a
pretty solid job, horrifically mutilating
the creature to a point of near-death, when
it suddenly yelled “KILL ME, YOU SACK OF
ORGANS, DO IT!”
And that order seemingly confused her, seeing
as only going halfway on killing the creature
was something she’d already done.
She remained motionless in the test chamber
until she was physically removed, and later
attempts to use her in 682’s termination
were fruitless.
The Foundation once tried to kill SCP-682,
the Hard to Destroy Reptile, with SCP-272,
an old iron nail.
This anomalous nail can kill its victims in
a number of ways: The nail bind’s a victim’s
shadow to the ground, indirectly binding the
victim itself as well by doing so.
If the shadow is displaced due to changes
in light source, the victim is flung and contorted
in the same direction the shadow has moved.
If the victim tries to destroy the nail, they
will surely die.
After the Foundation intentionally made the
lights in 682’s chamber strobe on and off
from various directions, causing the reptile
to be mutilated by being hurled around the
room.
Its body began producing an extremely powerful
light source, eliminating its own shadow and
keeping it safe.
The light was so bright that when D-Classes
entered the chamber to remove the nail - despite
wearing eye protection - they were afflicted
with permanent retinal damage.
And of course - in the end - SCP-682 was just
fine.
In one of their more desperate attempts to
kill off SCP-682, the Hard to Destroy Reptile,
the SCP Foundation employed the use of SCP-3802,
a bottle of anti-baldness ointment
known as “hare growth by dado.”
But not just any hair: If you
apply this to the skin of an adult,
they’ll break out in huge, painful,
tumorous masses that turn into giant,
Flemish rabbits. This anomalous chemical
was spritzed onto SCP-682 by the sprinklers,
causing the beast horrific pain and
massive, unchecked tumor growth.
As these tumors broke away and became
giant rabbits, they tore off 40%
of SCP-682’s body mass. However, it didn’t stick,
as SCP-682 ate the rabbits while it was
regenerating. Back to the drawing board!
Who would win: The Hard to Destroy Reptile,
or 9.15 million kilograms of bananas?
This is SCP-682 VS SCP-3521
When SCP-682 was cross-tested with SCP-3521
- A little yellow pill that makes bananas
manifest in the stomach of those who eat them
- the Foundation hoped to answer that question.
682 was tricked into eating the pill by hiding
it inside the body of a dead cow, which was
then fed to the monster.
As time passed, an absurd number of bananas
began to manifest in and around SCP-682, filling
its containment chamber and then the entire
facility.
However, just when it seemed 682 was crushed
under all that potassium, it began eating
the bananas faster than they could be produced.
And because bananas are each slightly naturally
radioactive, eating that many gave SCP-682
the ability to fire a powerful radiation beam
out of its mouth until 3521’s effects wore
off.
The craziest part?
This all occurred within a ten-minute period.
Guess you could say things went a little bananas
in there.
Ready for this one?
SCP-682 vs SCP-835 is one of the most horrifying
SCP-682 cross tests we have logged to date!
That’s right!
We have paired the Hard to Destroy Reptile
with the disgusting nightmare known as SCP-835,
a giant carnivorous coral polyp made from
living human matter!
When SCP-835 was released, the infectious
abomination pulled SCP-682 into its massive
gullet, dragging it down for a slow and painful
digestion, surrounded by the intense pressure
and screaming human faces of the beast’s
fleshy throat.
What was eventually ejected was little more
than SCP-682’s skeleton.
However, over time this skeleton regenerated
into a horrific hybrid of SCP-682 and SCP-835:
Covered in sticky tentacles, human faces spewing
acid, and infectious spores that could turn
others into monsters.
It breached containment and killed many.
The survivors had to be terminated to avoid
SCP-835 contamination spreading further.
SCP-682 Vs Godzilla: Who would take home the
gold in the battle of these mighty reptiles?
Godzilla, obviously, has the advantage in
terms of his offensive capabilities: He’s
considerably larger than SCP-682, and has
the incredible power of his atomic breath
- Capable of taking down other huge monsters
like King Ghidorah or the MUTOs.
However, SCP-682 has its trump card: Insane
adaptability.
When faced with Godzilla, it may adapt to
imitate the monster’s atomic breath, or
begin to grow to epic proportions to match
it in size.
In the end, it’s hard to know who would
win, but a true stalemate seems incredibly
likely.
It’s time for a clash of the titans: SCP-682, the
Hard to Destroy Reptile, SCP-106, the Old Man,
and SCP-953, the Polymorphic Humanoid.
This wasn’t even a Foundation cross-test:
Just an organic battle that occurred
during a massive containment breach.
SCP-953 and SCP-106 entered 682’s containment
chamber, at which point they all began staring at
each other, preparing for an attack. 106 began the
battle, sinking into the floor and grabbing 953,
trying to pull her into his pocket
dimension. She then grabbed 682,
resulting in all three of them being
pulled into the pocket dimension.
They all remained in there for five hours, before
returning, heavily injured from their fight.
106 returned to his chamber, 953 was recaptured
by Foundation personnel, and 682 regenerated
its 67% body mass loss. All three have
refused to speak about the incident since.
The cross-test between SCP-682 and SCP-173 with
high precision blades was a complete disaster.
Organized by Dr. Shenron, the two iconic
monsters were brought into a test chamber
and the blades were deployed,
cutting both of them into pieces.
Two D-Classes were sent in when the vacuum
system failed, and were killed by SCP-682’s
blobs of flesh, and the newly reformed
SCP-173. At this point, the battle began,
and 173 attacked the different blobs
of 682 flesh. Some blobs fought back,
while others reformed into a smaller
version of 682, which stared at 173.
Just like in the original test, a sniper
shot out the eyes of this smaller 682,
leading 173 to snap its neck. It then
regenerated and stared at 173 for
seventeen hours before the test was finally
ended. When 173 was taken back to its cell,
there was a power failure in the hallway, leading
to a site-wide containment breach and many deaths.
Dr. Shenron’s troubleshooting with
the incinerator system was seen as
the catalyst for this deadly power failure, and
he was relieved from duty shortly afterwards.
SCP-682 Vs The Gate Guardian.
Can the giant warrior with a
sword hotter than the sun finally
kill the Hard to Destroy Reptile?
When SCP-682 was brought in to hopefully
meet its ultimate destruction at the Gate
the Guardian Guards, it quipped,
“Is this meant to be the Garden?
This is not the Garden. The
Garden is far west of here.”
When the Gate Guardian struck 682, it was
grievously wounded, with only a single leg left.
As it regenerated, it snarled at the Gate
Guardian, saying, “Die? You command me
to die? Oh, wouldn't we all like that, but
this is my curse for suggesting the fruit.”
It struck again, and before passing
out from its injuries, 682 said,
“This is not the Garden, and
you are not Uriel. Pretender.”